πώς κινίται συκεκριμένια αγορά σήμερα τάξεη είναι μια αγορά που τα τηλευταία θα έεγα δέκατε
καπέντε χρόνια έχει τεράστεια αναυτυξη ας βασικός πιλώ να της κυπριακής οικονομίας πη ίοση χρόνια
πολύ λιγιέμενα στην κύπρο να πουδάσουν αυτή τη στιγμή εντελώς διαφορετικό των σκινικώ χουμε ένα
σηματικό αριθμό κύπριο που επιλέγουν να μίνουν στην κύπρο τη διαστιγμή έχουμε μια τεράστιο αριθμό
ελλαδιτών που έρχονται στην κύπρο έχουμε περίπου ίκοσιχιλιάδες έλλινα σπιτητές αυτή στηγμή στην κύπρο τρη
τα πέντε της εκαδώ του πληθισμού των φιτητώ είναι από την ελλάδα τεράστεια νέα εξέληξη
που κύρίως ξεκίνησε το δύο φιιάδες νέα δέκα μετά την κρίσει στην ελλάδα εψαχνά για
μια εναλλακτική και βεβαίως με τα ανάπτευξη τω ακατημαϊκών ιδριγμάτων έχεις πλέο πολλές επιλογές όμως
έχει φτάσει των κορεσμό δεν υπήρξ τον στρατηγικό πλάνο που θα έπρεπε στα αρχεικά στα
δια ανάπτυξης του δομέα αυτή η στιγμή ο τομίας είναι σε ένα προβληματικό στάδιο θα
αποκαλούσα σε ότι αφορά που πάμε τα επόμενα χρόνια γιατί από τη μια είναι λά
τα υτρήματα και δεν αναπτύετε μεδοννδιοριθμό οπληθισμό στο φιτηδώ το δεύτερο σημαντικό είναι η εξέληξη
με την ελλάδα όσον αφορά την κανάνόμο και την κάθοδο των λίγο μαριστιγμίο αλλά θα
έλεγα πολύ περισσότερο με την αλλαγή νομοθεσίας γιατί όπως γνωρίζουμε για πολλές δεκαϊτίες ήταν αντι
συνταγματικώ να υπάρχει διωτική εκπαίδευση ήταν ενάνδια στο σγ συνναγμα της ελλάδας οι κυβέρνηση μετσοδάκι
έχει αλλάξει το πλαίσιο αρα δίτητη δυναδότητα τα επόμενα χρόνια δεν έχει δεν έχουν αρχίσει
τη λιτουργία τους αλλά είναι πολύ κοντά συναρχίσουν τη λιτουργία τους κάποια παραακτήγματα ξένων πανεπιστιγμίων
στη ελλάδα που σημαί είνει ότι οι ελλαδίτες φιτητές θα έχουν την επιλογή τω να
μίνουν στην ελλάδα για ιδιωτικά πανεπιστμια που δεν υπάρχει αυτή τη στιγμή και ναι και
με την κάθοδο των ελληνικών πανεπιστιγμίωνστην κύπρο